I thought I saw that again I'm remind
[Music]
sorry your father's gone at some point
we have to face up to who we are who
were meant to be I think I know where my
dad went that's right in the middle of
the devil sea it would be an adventure
adventure what are you doing here Laura
seven years I've been on this island
your father they put me here now I see
the likeness intelligence
some recklessness
what do you know about my father Laura
there was more to my life than
boardrooms and business deals there's an
organization called Trinity to start a
global genocide you dad June you had a
bigger holiday got a knack for the
unexpected
you must stop for Laura promise me
[Music]
ladies first
open the tomb
don't your fingers pulling this trigger
you messed with the wrong family
[Music]
I just have one question
when cap needed help if I'd asked you
would you have come I guess we'll never
know but if you had you'd have never
been caught
I do some dumb things and the people I
love the most they pay the price thanks
to you we had to run
we're still running let's go
[Music]
[Music]
maybe you just need someone watching
your back
like a partner
hold on you gave her wings and blasters
so I take it you didn't have that tech
available for me no I did
honey mama what is it I have to go with
Roy
I was told to take him into hotel I said
that he was an enemy of the state take
off your dress and then exchange my
mother look at the doctor she needed
instead they cut his throat
there could be no witnesses so there
could be a choice
die or become a sparrow from this day
forward you will become space-weapons in
a global struggle for power you'll be
trained to a psychological manipulation
we must learn to push yourself beyond
all limitation take off your clothes
when we are finished with you the person
you were in a longer exist every human
being is a puzzle of need we must become
the missing piece and they will tell you
anything you have a gift you know how to
survive this is what you were meant to
do
whose iterator and the government his
last known contact is an American dead
claw same a very same pool yesterday are
we going to become friends telling you
want
it's just about the only matter cuz of
what you can do for them work with me
and make this man pay you are better at
this than any of us your only problem is
you have a soul
and we can't trust a word that comes out
of her mouth
there's some house or Gaussian
if she's compromised she will be
eliminated
what have you done
you belong to them they won't ever let
go I'll find a way
are you aware that olivia is in love
with your boyfriend she's mine we
stopped Penelope
damn Miguel Olivia let's get this party
started
tight garden truth what are your
intentions with our suite Olivia I
needed to find someone with friends that
I could trick into coming here I could
tell Olivia was an easy target I brought
you all up here cuz I'm okay with
strangers dying if it means I get to
live what the hell
games will okay wherever you go whatever
you do it'll find you okay yeah
something really weird has been going on
ever since Mexico oh come on
serious I'm seeing things truth all
right there dear I know it sounds insane
just a little this fine young lady here
dared me to show you my business Carter
said tell the truth or you die do the
dare or you die refused to play you
don't screw this
you die
we're not playing the game
it's playing us so what do we do only
choose truth wait I'm sorry
touch me again and I'll break that hand
truth that's how it works only game
decides honey break Olivia's hand you
have to do it look as pissed as I am at
you right now
there's no way I'm gonna break your hand
you don't really have a choice God just
do it this game is too smart half the
people in this photo are now dead we
need to find the what started all this
how do we get out of this game a lot
you can't it's on the ends of all the
players are dead baby returns next dare
me to chew she's in front of you to kill
truth or dare
do you know what it is to make your
dreams come true lil you seen your king
dusters I don't deserve you
I love you so much but you don't know me
I want the know what the deal is when is
crazy part 10 this kind of thing hurts
my reputation daddy's gotta go
oh no soda your girlfriend has secrets
he lost me taking him Zin [ __ ] off you
talkin something's going on
you need to maintain sense a human
you're gonna give me some trouble big
boy are you gonna channel that famous
Amish serenity
I need to tell you something
discuss top right now made a secret
anymore to do anything for her
say your swamp
I can t talk cabesnoz
you
hey guys how was the party it was really
fun
bassist he's wearing a woman's sweater
and he's drunk
well he didn't drive drunk and he's home
before curfew so that's what I thought
we know yeah we're good my name's Simon
the most part my life is totally normal
I have a family that I actually like and
there's my friends we do everything
friends do we drink way too much dice
coffee walking on carbs so I'm just like
you except I have one huge ass secret
hey I like your boots I said I like your
boots
bye nobody knows I'm gay
[Music]
have you seen the new post about the
closeted gay kid at school what what do
you think it is call you back you're
glue
I'm just like you
this was mistake it's nice to know
there's another guy at school with the
same secret when did you first realize
it was a bunch of little things like my
first girlfriend I think I'm fine with
you
Wow thank you be right back wasn't my
proudest moment sometimes I think I'm
destined to care so much about one
person it nearly kills me
me too I'm done living in a world where
I don't get to be Who I am
I deserve a great love story and I want
someone to share with
have you ever been in love
think so
these last few years it's almost like I
can feel you holding your breath I'm
supposed to be the one that decides when
and where and who knows that's supposed
to be my thing disclaimer this is about
to get romantic his effort you're not in
a heavy are you she's cute but she's not
really my type not because she's black I
love black women not like you know I
have a thing for black women I just I
just I just love fall ringing Jake your
father always said he wanted you to be a
pilot he said a lot of things I'm not
hero like he was the kaiju they're gonna
come back we're not to be stuck waiting
for someone else to come save my ass
cadets you better gear up
[Music]
this is the way the world has how'd they
get into our world
someone let them in someone from our
world
who is that definitely not one of ours
[Music]
this is your chance to make things right
we're gonna need more violets we have
them
there are pilots we remember as legends
but they didn't start that way they
started out like us this is our time to
make a difference
do you understand
Jakub pilots do you understand one way
to find out
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
gonna be a long day what we tell we
fight
Oh
[Music]
where is my daughter
people who just disappear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're telling me that the king of a
third-world country runs around and a
bulletproof cat suit
why don't you ask him yourself because
he's right outside my king stop it Black
Panther leaves
[Music]
it was he's coming tonight car wash me
do mine hope you ready bro I'm just
getting started
[ __ ]
showoff
[Music]
I want the weapons my secrets all mine
this ends today
[Applause]
God face you of a smart defeat at night
get tickets now
[Music]